unos últimos preparativos antes de
partir este equipo humanitario está a
punto de salir hacia la parte central
del Mediterráneo Este es el Ocean viking
un barco fletado por la ong sos
mediterráneo para prestar asistencia a
las embarcaciones de migrantes que huyen
de África con la esperanza de llegar a
Europa
durante nuestras misiones vemos
embarcaciones que no están en
condiciones de emprender un viaje Así
cuando los encontramos algunos se han
quedado sin combustible o están perdidos
en el mar esta vez el barco se verá
obligado a respetar la nueva ley
aprobada recientemente por el gobierno
italiano en materia de operaciones de
salvamento marítimo ahora está prohibido
realizar rescates múltiples aunque esta
ong tenga capacidad para salvar varias
embarcaciones de migrantes en peligro de
naufragio
en cuanto Terminamos el primer rescate
nos dan un puerto para desembarcar y nos
dicen que navegamos hacia él a la máxima
velocidad eso va en contra del derecho
internacional que estipula que si un
capitán está en condiciones de ayudar a
un barco en dificultades debe debe
intervenir este barco fletado por
médicos Sin fronteras es el primero
sancionado por la nueva ley las
autoridades italianas les acusan de no
facilitar información suficiente sobre
su último rescate marítimo el resultado
una multa de hasta 10.000 euros y la
inmovilización del barco durante 20 días
aquí en el puerto de augusta en sicilia
está detenciones ilegítima se recibe la
noticia con mucha frustración y con
mucha Pues con mucha preocupación
pensando sobre todo en las personas que
podríamos
asistir y que bueno pues por desgracia
no va a poder ser hay una intención
Clara de mantener a los barcos de
rescate lejos de la zona de operaciones
mientras esperan a que finalice el
periodo de restricción el equipo prepare
el material para la próxima misión en la
ruta de migrantes más mortífera del
mundo en los últimos 10 años casi 25.000
personas han perecido intentando cruzar
el Mediterráneo